[Música]
es para que nací
ha hecho que el hombre empiece a crear
un montón de plataformas con un montón
de cartas para que el mismo hombre pueda
tener una capa de una búsqueda y una
capacidad de elección de poder elegir
distintos
lugares distintas cosas y están un poco
más cercano a lo que cree que es bueno
para uno
y ahí aparece también hemos sido tan
buscadores que aparece que vamos seguido
seguido muy seguido a un doctor de
doctores que se ha convertido en uno de
los más sabios de los sabios de los
recontra sabios y está siempre 24 horas
atentos listos para nosotros para
podernos guiar al mejor destino de
nuestra vida y ese doctor se llama el
doctor google
el doctor hugo nos acerca hasta qué
medicinas debemos tomar cuál es lo más
cercano estos son los síntomas para
parar y tenemos que no
las diferentes instituciones de
educación también hacen un esfuerzo
importante para tratar de acercarte de
la mejor manera posible a lo que
seguramente está al alcance tuyo al
alcance que loca palabra
que está al alcance y que no está al
alcance
pero si hay destino si yo tengo algo
específico sí o no si para algo este
que tengo que estar buscando para donde
debo ir
existen dos opciones dentro de lo que yo
pienso o veo del ser humano
en la cual está
por la cual está determinado a vivir dos
opciones
el aquel que está buscando de manera
positiva por supuesto poder lograr y
encontrar un objetivo este proactivo
para su vida estas opciones es lo bueno
y lo excelente
cuál del lado de mala
pero la excelente es mejor
como encuentro entonces la excelente
para donde voy yo a no ser que usted
quiera lo bueno que está bien sabe que
he podido notar he podido notar chicos
que
la mayoría de nuestro planeta se siente
tranquila en lo bueno y trata de ponerle
excusas como digamos no es que yo no soy
pues éste
una persona ambiciosa
yo soy humilde
yo trato de ser no no no yo hermano
porque no tranquilito nomás
pero dentro de su corazón está buscando
lo excelente pero se conforma con lo
bueno
porque está en medio de esta baraja
entonces aparece esta historia
maravillosa que nos remonta al comienzo
de nuestras clases del colegio o de un
espacio en el cual nos involucra con
nuestra persona ya que están estos tres
amigos tremendos hermosos alucinantes
que se quieren un montón que pasaron los
años y empiezan a compartir sus primeras
historias sus primeras historias están
llenas de chichones del beso de la
primera chica el cual te gusta más
ya nos gusta los tres la misma que
imparta la cadera ya la meta
y esas historias después se van
mezclando con las otras historias las
cuales nos sugieren espacios de
complicidad y esos splash espacios de
complicidad involucran amor guau una de
las importantes claves para poder
encontrar el que nací no se involucran
tolerancia guau otra de las claves
importantes para poder encontrar el que
nací nos involucra el poder comunicarnos
con otras personas de manera poderosa y
este avanzar nos lleva hasta qué
estos jóvenes llegan al bachillerato
y el cabeza el que siempre tiene la idea
primera el que dice qué tal se hace
objeto del que la suelta primero ese que
la va llevando el que agarre dice yo voy
a estudiar medicina pero hermano los
tres somos hermanos y le hemos metido en
el comienzo así que los para elevado me
trae medicina o para polo médico más
grandes
y se mete en un camino maravilloso que
involucra amistad que involucra amor que
involucra historias lindas
y se va nosotros la medicina
al segundo año a uno de los amigos le
parece que el cadáver de que llegó
no está adecuado como para que sus dedos
se acerquen porque la tripa
no son del color que me esperaba y dice
que estoy haciendo está papa
el otro amigo
al tercer libro de medicina que era un
blog más grande que un valor
dijo en que me metiste mi hermano le
echó la culpa al amigo
y 2 desertaron
mala decisión
el para quien así no puede estar
determinado por el llamado de otro
tú para que nací es tuyo
y tenéis que descubrirlo
no fomenta la flojera por ahí está esta
suerte de baraja desde un montón de
decisiones donde uno pueda buscar porque
no hay un sobreviviente hombre uno está
buscando poder encontrar más o menos
algo cercano a lo que te gusta pero lo
que te gusta cercano a lo que te gusta
no quiere decir que esté cercano a lo
que debe ser ay papá
pero es lo que está cercano a lo que vos
debes ser es lo que al final te va a ser
feliz
aunque no lo sepas desde el comienzo
aunque en el comienzo parezca raro
descubrir este este para que nací va a
tener que involucrar poder entender un
par de cosas y poder descubrir un par de
cosas dentro de tu caminata
hay priístas porque ahorita deben estar
preguntando matan varias pues como
cepilla eso hermano
si google no lo tiene sino como hermanos
quieren saber cómo se piden así
ya no quiere
o quieres seguir metiéndole una materia
mañana son psicólogos pasados un
futbolista es un arquitecto de presión
bailarines de tango después o mismo
cuando terminas de ser mismo se van a
francia porque se enamoraron de un
francés y después estar con él francia
dijeron no me corrigen se animan y te
vas con el alemán y después de terminar
con el alemán estás en un bote
maravilloso en venecia diciendo como
extraño bolivia
el asma
es demasiado viaje y demasiada pérdida
de
y ustedes y nosotros no tenemos tiempo
para estar perdiendo el tiempo sino para
invertir el tiempo en el tiempo que debe
ser correcto
se entiende nosotros no tenemos tiempo
para perder el tiempo sino para invertir
el tiempo del tiempo que es correctos y
el tiempo que es correcto es el diseño
que tiene los días de tu vida
los días de tu vida
nos detenemos y vemos características
algunas características en nuestra vida
que nos pueden mostrar más o menos para
que nacimos hay aptitudes no podéis ir
familia por la respuesta absurda y
básica de decir soy un bueno para nada
es una respuesta muy floja mi hermano no
porque no sabes lo que me ha pasado no
estoy hablando de lo que te pasa de lo
que haya pasado ni te quiero faltar el
respeto con respecto a lo que hayas
pasado para nada viejo
para nada pero no te puedes detener en
la básica respuesta de decir soy un
bueno para nada porque no existe no hay
persona humana que sea buena para nada
de repente descubrir que tenemos una
buena actitud para poder hablar para
poder conversar no te da miedo el
público qué sé yo quizás será por el
lado de la abogacía son un escritor
maravilloso será por el lado de los
libros de la literatura
tenéis ideas propositivas que pueden
cambiar al mundo será por ese lado
ay ay hay pistas pistas que están
dentro de vos es imposible que el hombre
no haya visto una pista
pero por alguna razón loquísima este
nosotros decimos estas pistas son muy
fáciles la vida es difícil debe ser algo
más heavy lo que tengo que buscar por
texto sacrificarse
y ponemos el lugar del sacrificio no en
el lugar que tiene que estar si se
necesita sacrificio pero el poner la
palabra sacrificio en el lugar no
adecuado friega el propósito
anda stand
cuando pone sacrificio en el lugar que
no se ataje en la pista y decidí pucha
no pero esto ya me lo sé
debe ser algo más grave porque la vida
es grave hay que meterles coñac
entonces ahí te vas
y grave porque vos mismo lo estás
haciendo grave guardar el lugar de la
tesis de la lucha y de la batalla para
el lugar que sea adecuado porque lo vas
a necesitar no gastes la botellita del
esfuerzo antes de tiempo esa botellita
está para ser gastada cuando corresponde
si se necesita pero estamos tan tipo
que las mezclamos y hacemos una especie
de doctor chapatín mezclando pociones en
los lugares que no son adecuados con las
herramientas adecuadas
con las herramientas adecuadas
una vez descubrir ponele
el para que nací
tenéis que empezar a hacer un plan yo
particularmente y esto es algo mío del
matamba porque está medio coco
no ven yo particularmente decidí
entregarme para que nací
al más alto rey ya rastafari
pero eso es mío otro decidido en caminar
por el tema del libro otros deciden
encontrar su para que nació que hay
tengo esta pista ok tengo esta o esto
también
y pide una fórmula siempre tú para quien
así aunque sea parecido a otro va a ser
único están conmigo tú para quien así va
a ser único viejo va a ser único aunque
sea parecido a otro hay harto cantante
pero hay un matamba
todo negro
y es porque encontrarás la fórmula y
encontrará que sí amo el fútbol yo
quería jugar fútbol y juego bien loco
pero dentro de esa cancha había una
melodía que se pasaba en mi cabeza todo
el tiempo como una barrera imposible de
sortear
y como ya veía la música que estaba la
música claro la conozco pero la vida es
más compleja trataba de hacerle lado y
buscar algo más completo por el amor
cuando ya estaba ahí
si seguramente es pero en este momento
se están despertando en ustedes muchas
de las cosas
esto estaba pues ahí hacer datos mail
que bueno es una buena señal loco porque
puedo ver sus caritas lo bueno de estar
acá es que lo veo a todos
y es allá
una vez encontrada encontrar gente para
que nací tenéis que buscar un plan tenés
que idear un plan
es ser un tonto aquel que no idea y no
traza un plan un plan que tenga objetivo
un plan que tenga un objetivo tras ese
objetivo me pase una vez te encuentres
sumerjas en lo suyo
sumerges en lo suyo y métase con todo
sin miedo una de las cosas que nosotros
hacemos es donde cometemos un error es
que cuando encontramos el para que
nacemos creemos que ya descubrimos todo
y no es ahí cuando comienza la batalla
es ahí cuando recién para saber quién
sos
antes de eso antes de todo lo que hayas
vivido antes de descubrir el para que
nací
simplemente es una sombra de lo que eso
nadie te conoce te van a empezar a
conocer a partir del para que nací eso
es una voz de esperanza para vos porque
todavía tulum no ha salido a partir de
él para que nací es que te van a conocer
te das cuenta loco
hay esperanza entonces una vez
encontrase eso y empezaba a meter un
plan y empezar a ejecutarlo dale para
adelante por favor cuida a quien
contrastó planes tus sueños de repente
tú para quien así está en ese negocio
maravilloso que vos lo estás viendo y
que no salió en bolivia nunca sabes que
le voy a meter esto y le voy a meter a
los otros y qué te parece mi hermano
jota te vas a perder plata va mal te va
a ir para para la cual de richard uriona
tal idioma
perdió plata idealmente verdad
y empezar a vivir el sueño lleno que no
correspondía vos entonces estás viviendo
como la historia de los tres amigos que
se metieron a donde no tenían que estar
cuéntele su sueño a una persona que está
dispuesta a soñar con usted o mejor no
le diga nada a nadie y avance loco
pero cuide con quién habla no hable con
despidos del sueño sino con
constructores con personas que lo van a
llevar al objetivo que lo van a ayudar a
alcanzar dentro de esta búsqueda del
sueño vas a encontrar tres pasos
fundamentales que vas a requerir de
visión
y la final perseverancia
efe visión y perseverancia la cosa es
que la fe no se puede comprar en la
esquina lo
la visión si viejo mirada al frente
miran al objetivo nada puede cambiar eso
y la perseverancia es de acuerdo a los
obstáculos que baja pues vas a encontrar
van a ver obstáculos el encontrar ver
para qué nacido usted es de los
obstáculos para estar ahí los obstáculos
por usted tiene que ser persevera
perseverancia es lo que vas a tener y lo
que vas a necesitar fundamental ahora
hasta dónde llega la perseverancia están
listo para saber esto hasta cuándo es la
perseverancia quiere saber para siempre
para siempre
eso no para nunca
si estás dispuesto a encontrarte y
realmente a conocerte vas a necesitar
perseverancia pero aún si tuvieras
perseverancia si tuviera fe si tuvieras
misión si tuvieras un plan y si conoces
el para qué nací te falta un ingrediente
muy importante un mejor dicho 2
amor
es 1
sin amor todo lo demás se desbarata y el
segundo
bueno ya terminó el tiempo así que no
les voy a decir el segundo gracias este
ha sido
el tiempo
gracias el pasivo
parece que quieren saber cuáles quieren
saber con el segundo de verdad con todo
su corazón pero tan listos y lo
ejecutaría y lo haría con todo su
corazón con todos oye que así le falte
un diente así que él hace o dice vuelvo
en blanco
el ingrediente secreto es servir
si no estás dispuesto a servir a los
demás
nada va a servir
servir
y servir
lo sé pero lo que va a ser bueno verlos
su luz es importante hace falta y estoy
ansioso por conocer lo de verdad para
que naschy
les
[Música]